hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be taking a look at the 1968 game
between Boris Spassky and Essen Geller
this was a game played in the candidates
it was round
six of the candidates I believe and
Boris Spassky had the white pieces here
we're gonna see how he approached this
game against Geller the game started
with E for c5 Knight c3 actually d6 and
G 396 this is of course the closed
Sicilian you don't see this one as often
this these days usually players favor
the open Sicilian the the Rasul emo
plenty of other lines that give white
somewhat of a pressing edge sometimes
the closest iliyan not as well respected
these days but it does give white some
very clear plans which we'll see in the
game so of course it's called the
closest Ilion because you're not playing
d for opening the center you're playing
d3 keeping the center closed black fee
and kiddos on the Queen on the Kings
side we see f4 Knight f6 Knight f3 note
that white pushes this pawn to f4 before
developing this Knight saves them a
little bit of time in the long run black
castles white castles as well and now
black plays rook b8 and this is kind of
the the theme of the game that we'll see
here this is how a lot of close Sicilian
games go white pretty much commits to
playing on the Kings side using these
ponds to launch an f5 attack opening up
files opening up diagonals on the Kings
side this is where white is trying to
kill the black King in the meantime
though black is using his advantage on
the Queen side using this spatial
advantage to push all the way through
and try to create enough threats on the
Queen side to get here in time before
white checkmates black and this is the
kind of opening kind of middle game that
you get actually when you see a closed
center things like the closed center and
allow each side to play on on different
sides of the board and it makes for an
interesting game we see whites start
with h3 of course like I said he's going
to launch a pawn storm on the Kings side
in the meantime black wastes no time is
immediately placed b5
like I said watching his own attack on
the queenside now in order to stop the
b4 move what actually goes for a three
here these days I think g4 is a bit more
common just totally ignoring black on
the Queen side but a3 makes some sense
you don't want to play b4 immediately
because this structure actually turns
out to be a bit better for white the
rook on the a file is going to be more
relevant than the half-open C file so
instead black plays a five further
preparing B for white takes this time to
get developed with Bishop III black
breaks through with B for white does
capture this and now we see 92 in this
case black cannot step on the a file
just yet of course so he needs Bishop b7
to prepare that and now white plays this
move b3 smooth is aimed at kind of
slowing down blacks Queen side pawn
storm although I'm not a huge fan of it
in positions like these I really like
just ignoring the opponent on the Queen
side until he makes a substantial threat
obviously if he makes a substantial
threat you have to respond to it but in
the meantime I think what should be
focusing more on the King side play b3
not a bad move though we see rook a8
from from black now taking control of
this file and rather than trade these
rooks or let this rook sit on the a file
where it might run into some trouble
eventually Spassky plays rook c1 I kind
of like this move it invites the Fox
into the henhouse as yes or Sarah one
would say one of my favorite chess
analogies that I've heard but in this
case the the Fox kind of has no teeth
you know he's attacking the c2 pond but
we've already defended this pawn with
our rook and it's going to take black
quite a while to be able to make any
threats on the Queen side of the board
here and this gives white some time to
finally follow through on his own play
on the Kings side with g4 to start black
now plays Queen a8 trying to get more
pieces in on this a a file and now white
plays a very common maneuver with Queen
e1 eyeing some of these squares on the
side Queen a6 is blacks choice and now
perhaps f5 should have been played for
white he first plays queen f2 keeping an
eye on some dark squares as well perhaps
hinting at even ef5 breaks although I I
kind of doubt it here in the game black
plays Knight a7
perhaps rerouting this night to b5 and
opening up this diagonal and now white
does play the keep on break f5 in
position and now we see that blacks
Queen side play is simply far too slow
he tries 95 getting this night to a
better Square try and get it to a3
trying to break to unseat break through
on to c2 y it simply takes on g6 we see
H takes g6 and now Knight g5 from white
and there are threats on the F file
there are threats on the H file there
are threats everywhere on the board for
white here black does continue with
night a3 trying his best to make
something happen on the Queen side but
after Queen h4 and the threats are going
to be too much around blacks King rook
c8 and then I'll let you at home try and
find the finishing blow here
well not quite finishing but you know
that the start of the finishing blow go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find it of course it is the classic
sacrifice rook takes f6 and now black is
doomed
of course Bishop takes f6 is horrible it
allows checkmating to eat xf6 is a
little bit of a better try this is what
black does in the game
Queen h7 check to follow King f8 and
then do we retreat this night away all
right now it's attacked after all of
course we do not we play the nice
follow-up sacrifice Knight takes f7 of
course if you take this piece you're
gonna run into Bishop h6
and after rook g8 Knight f4 and you are
going to get crushed so after a night of
7 this piece was not captured instead
rooks rook takes c2 was played Bishop h6
still a very natural follow-up you see
rook takes rook check Knight takes King
takes bishop but now it's simply over
Queen takes g7 King e8
now g5 makes even more threats threats
of queening in fact f5 is played to try
to prevent this we see Queen takes g6
check and now after he takes f5 this
bishops opened up and black resigns of
course the game could have continued
with King b6 when some trades might have
occurred and this pawn is simply going
to Queen nothing this trick can do to
stop it
despite black quote-unquote being up in
exchange here so a very nice game by
Boris Spassky here and shows the power
of the closed Sicilian when the when the
King side attack it does break through
in full force and it shows that with
black you do need to be very careful you
need to create threats immediately on
the Queen side or else you're simply
going to get checkmated thank you very
much for joining me for this episode of
game review my name is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time